- Is it okay if we French
kiss in front of you?
- Leah, Leah's friend.
That sounds mighty fine.
Oh, yeah.
Lick her blank face.
- Do you wanna join us?
- I thought you'd never ask.
(groaning)
Oh, no.
Whole thing already out.
It's already out.
- [Mother] Edward, my dear.
- Horse feathers, it's your mother.
- It's too late, my
Woodrow's about to Wilson.
- [Mother] Dinner's ready!
- I'm...
Coming!
- God!
I love fucking you both,
but in such different ways.
(moaning)
- What the?
So hysterical paroxysm is.
- [Woman] This is my first orgasm.
- Okay, now her I believe.
- Behold, vibration for women's health.
- Oh, my penis is right
next to the baby's head.
(screaming)
I'm rich!
- [Mother] Oh!
Oh, God!
Dina!
(shrieking)
- Jesus, is that what's
supposed to happen?
- Yeah, sounds like your
mama just won an orgasm.
- Yeah, oh.
(turkey gobbling)
Oh, yeah, you want that gravy?
Oh, yeah, you do!
Oh, my gravy boat's so full of gravy.
Oh, yeah, oh, God.
Oh, yeah, oh, that's right.
Oh!
Get stuffed!
- Oh, I love you so much Miss Whistle.
You're always around my
neck, even all the time.
(whistle tooting)
Uh-oh.
My bed went sick again.
(somber music)
(sobbing)
- I'm sorry, Andrew.
- It's okay.
No, I made in the crate.
- Shut up, Maurice.
Can't you see he's mine now.
You both are.
(laughing)
- Okay, it's just that
it's caked to my fur.
(moaning)
(laughing)
- Lola, I can't help but think.
Oh, God.
- Okay, but after this, no more.
- Of course.
- It's actually very freeing to know
that this is the last time.
(moaning)
(sniffing loudly)
(groaning)
- Little more.
Little bit more.
(intense music)
- I need this so bad.
You don't know how far I came.
If I can close my eyes,
I can.
Oh, really?
Yeah, honey.
Yeah!
(groaning loudly)
Oh, we fucking came together.
- I bought with all my 40 year old money.
- Yeah, I'm also 40.
I know your grandparents.
- Shut up, shut up, shut up.
I'm 40!
- Thank you, sir.
(mystical music)
(heart beat thumping)
- [Maurice] Missy, huh?
(screaming)
- Oh, shit!
(gasping)
(groaning)
It's everywhere, it's
between my goddamn toes.
(dramatic music)
(moaning)
- Okay, oh, my God.
Was that, was that it?
Did it happen?
- That was totally something.
- [Maurice] Here we go, visualize.
Focus.
Interesting.
Yes.
(moaning)
Well how about that.
Some tomato did it this time.
(mumbling)
- You're screaming.
You get soaked, your face is all twisted,
but you just wanna go
right back on that ride.
- No, can't slow it down.
Can't slow it down.
- Fuck it, if you're okay
with it, I'm okay with it.
- I'm okay with it.
(moaning)
- Jai ho.
Look at her sinewy arms.
- Susan, show me your top naked.
- Yes.
- Oh, God.
- And she's got fallopian tubes.
- Oh, God!
Okay, so, Susan, what's it
like to be in human resources?
(sighing)
I'm done.
- Oh, wow, choo choo, I'm doing it.
Oh!
- Yes, you are.
- Yeah I am.
- I just said that I am, Jesus.
Oh, I can feel a Charley horse coming on.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, I think my pena has to make a kaka.
Oh!
I think I'm gonna make sick.
(shrieking)
Thank you, I'm sorry.